i was
dozing off i was so comfortable last
night oh yeah
the life foam down there mother's arm oh
it is
i know it is when we stayed out here
last night
looking for a bite now if we could get a
bluefin tuna we'd be closer to doing
what we came down to the outer banks to
do
and that makes the money can dominate
the tuna fishery
so i'm gonna see a big flat spot
today's the day where you will see the
flat spot
holy dude the mother lode's down here
i'm marking them pretty good under the
boat right now come on
fish time is of the essence when we're
down here doing this for a paycheck
it is a situation where i need to catch
fish we need to put
money in our pockets
come on man come on fish oh
there he is izzy yep
there he is i foul it got him on the
stick
come on boys we need this one is he
still on
yep oh yeah
oh yeah the one-arm bandit is back in
down baby
anytime you stayed overnight and put in
that extra time and you look out in the
distance you see another boat actually
fighting a fish and you hadn't had a
bite it is a bummer
if we don't fall behind and we can get a
couple nice fish
we'll be right there in the hunt for the
top spot there so as much as we're here
to make money it would be nice to finish
this thing out strong
somewhere near the top of that
leaderboard yeah baby
don't bother me now big money mountain
i hope she's big enough i hope it's the
right one man
it looked big enough did you get a good
look out yeah
come on come on days are going away
got a nice fish on here first thing in
the morning sounded like a big fish look
like a big fish
we're hoping for the best put some meat
on this deck
come on baby show me some love
i think we lost them man they're gone
broke the joe booth
damn it we just broke the hook
first fish of the morning not how you
want to start it off but
step back out try again at least we know
they're here
oh man as hard as these things are to
come by man
and as bad as we need one the strongest
hook you can buy
oh i hope this ain't gonna be one of
them trips